-Elle s'entend aussi bien
avec le rappeur Akhenaton
qu'avec le couple Macron.
Mon invitée est à l'aise partout,
avec tout le monde,
et c'est peut-être cela qui a fini
par la mener à la politique.
Générique
...
Sabrina Agresti-Roubache,
bonjour.
-Bonjour.
-Il y a un meeting
dont tout le monde se souvient
dans la campagne de 2017,
c'est celui
de la porte de Versailles.
On s'en souvient pourquoi ?
Parce que c'est le fameux meeting
de...
-C'EST NOTRE PROJET !
-Je me suis dit
qu'il avait dû avoir
un sacré bon chauffeur de salle,
pour se mettre dans cet état.
J'ai regardé le début de meeting.
-C'est horrible.
J'ai pas vu les images.
*-Vous m'entendez ?
Ouais, un, deux...
Le micro marche ?
Bonjour.
Donc, je m'appelle Sabrina.
Je suis née
dans l'un des arrondissements
les plus pauvres d'Europe.
Moi, je viens
de cette zone très compliquée
et où l'éducation m'a aidée.
C'est vrai, sans éducation,
on ne peut pas y arriver.
-Alors,
c'est votre témoignage à vous.
Vous étiez très éloignée
de la politique,
et vous vous être retrouvée là,
micro en main,
devant des milliers de personnes.
Que s'est-il passé ?
-Je me pose encore la question.
C'est l'histoire d'une rencontre
assez improbable, en réalité,
où Emmanuel Macron
vient lancer sa campagne à Marseille
et il demande à ses équipes
d'organiser un dîner.
C'est ça, le départ,
avec le monde socio-économique,
et plutôt des non-politiques,
des chefs d'entreprise,
des associatifs...
Donc, je me retrouve à table
dans un restaurant
assez en vue de Marseille.
C'est Brigitte Macron
qui m'installe à côté d'elle.
Moi, à l'époque,
je venais de rencontrer
celui qui deviendra mon mari,
et je vais la voir en lui disant :
"Brigitte, c'est super adorable
que je sois à côté de toi..."
Je l'ai tutoyée tout de suite.
-C'est direct !
-Oui, moi...
"Je peux être
avec Jean-Philippe ?
"Tu peux me mettre à côté de lui,
et tu me remplaces ?"
Elle me dit :
"C'est Jean-Philippe
"qu'on va déplacer."
-C'est le début
d'une rencontre marquante,
mais ça s'est passé
un mois avant votre rencontre
avec Emmanuel Macron.
Ce qui m'intéresse, c'est pourquoi
il vous a choisie vous,
alors qu'il vous connaissait
à peine ?
-C'est Brigitte qui m'appelle.
Ils sont tous les deux.
Elle me dit :
"T'es pas obligée,
"mais tu peux ouvrir son meeting ?"
-Pourquoi vous ?
-Sincèrement, c'est à eux qu'il faut
poser la question, à lui, notamment.
Moi, je...
En réalité, j'ai pas la réponse.
Quelqu'un
que vous ne connaissez pas,
avec qui on a échangé, après,
on s'est échangé les numéros,
mais je ne sais pas.
Alors, est-ce que c'est...
Lui aussi est assez instinctif,
est assez...
Enfin, moi, en tout cas,
c'est l'un des points communs
que j'ai avec lui.
-Il s'est dit que vous étiez
la bonne personne ?
-Au bon moment,
et qui était capable de le faire.
Parler devant 15 000 personnes,
quand vous n'avez jamais pris
la parole...
-Mais vous êtes devenue amie
avec les Macron en une soirée.
Quand on vous connaît,
on a l'impression
que c'est quelque chose de naturel.
Vous êtes capable de devenir amie
avec n'importe qui, de n'importe où.
Vous diriez que c'est un don ?
-Alors, c'est pas
avec n'importe qui, au contraire.
J'aime ou j'aime pas.
Je suis comme un petit animal.
C'est pour ça que la politique,
c'est compliqué, pour moi.
Je vois bien
le nombre de compositions
qu'il faut faire, le nombre...
Enfin, l'abnégation que ça demande.
Donc, non, mais par contre,
j'aime les gens.
Moi, la chose qui est vraie,
Je me soucie peu
de la couleur politique,
mais depuis toujours.
Je pense pas que les étiquettes
fassent les hommes.
Ce serait trop facile.
-Emmanuel Macron et Marseille...
On sait qu'Emmanuel Macron
est un grand fan de l'OM,
mais ça va au-delà.
Il a envie de faire de Marseille
le laboratoire
de sa politique.
Vous tenez un rôle là-dedans.
On vous surnomme souvent
"La vigie marseillaise des Macron".
Vous êtes d'accord ?
-Oui, parce que j'ai pas attendu
d'être élue
pour parler et travailler
sur Marseille avec lui, notamment.
Il aime Marseille,
c'est une sincérité.
Il l'explique assez simplement...
Ce qui le relie à Marseille...
En réalité, il est marseillais
dans le tempérament.
A Marseille, il se sent bien.
Il a quand même cette fougue,
ce côté rebelle.
-Vous l'informez
de ce qui se passe ?
-Et lui donner le vrai son
de la rue.
Qu'est-ce qui est intéressant ?
Déformation professionnelle :
je ne sais pas mentir.
Je ne sais pas travestir.
Il sait que tous les mots
qui sortent de ma bouche
et qui sont écrits
ne sont que sincérité.
Je suis assez cash,
je le reconnais.
Quand je pense un truc, je le dis.
Il sait que j'ai aussi
le sens de la confidentialité,
du secret.
Il y a des choses qu'on se dit
et que je dirai jamais,
jusqu'à ma mort.
Ca partira avec moi.
La réalité sur la vigie...
On est une vigie
quand on est capable
de donner l'alerte,
mais aussi
de dire ce qui va bien.
La vigie
dans tous les sens du terme.
-Vous avez une autre qualité,
c'est que vous êtes capable
de faciliter des rencontres,
de provoquer des choses
un peu inattendues, inespérées.
Il vous a confié
une mission assez étonnante,
en 2020 : de travailler au
rapprochement
entre la majorité
et la droite marseillaise,
Renaud Muselier,
en particulier,
alors que vous êtes de gauche.
Vous étiez novice en politique
et vous avez réussi.
Comment vous avez fait ?
-Alors, vous savez quoi ?
J'ai déployé...
Justement, j'ai évité...
Enfin, j'ai pas fait de politique.
Je suis allée voir Renaud Muselier
simplement,
en lui disant :
"Il y a un danger RN."
La réalité, vous savez...
Ce n'est pas quand on ne salue pas
les députés RN à la buvette
qu'on combat leurs idées.
Moi, je les salue,
mais je les combats.
La réalité, c'est que nous,
on est vraiment confrontés
à une vague RN,
et en région sud, encore plus.
On est l'une des régions
les plus exposées.
-C'est ce qui vous a aidée
à le convaincre ?
-Je lui ai parlé avec le coeur.
Lui, c'est un politique.
Il m'a dit :
"La politique, c'est sérieux."
-Sous-entendu
que vous ne l'étiez pas ?
"là, on fait de la politique".
Je lui ai répondu :
"Je sais, mais je viens te voir
non pas avec une âme de politique,
"je viens te voir
parce qu'il y a un enjeu pour nous.
"Tu es marseillais,
je le suis aussi.
"On se connaît un peu.
"Le président de la République
a compris l'enjeu sur la vague RN,
"et c'est le moment
de travailler ensemble."
-Avec votre personnalité,
ça ne semble pas un hasard
si votre vie s'est construite
autour de rencontres :
les Macron,
et puis une autre rencontre,
avant, bien avant,
celle d'Akhenaton,
figure emblématique du groupe IAM.
Cette rencontre a changé
le cours de votre vie ?
-Oui, elle a changé
le cours de ma vie,
surtout le cours de ma carrière.
Je l'ai connu assez jeune,
très jeune.
-Juste après le bac.
-Voilà.
Je suis née à Félix-Pyat,
et dans ce quartier,
les gens... Tous les personnages
de "Comme un aimant"
sont des amis à lui de Félix-Pyat.
C'est le premier long-métrage
coréalisé
par Akhenaton et Kamel Saleh,
qui est aussi un jeune
de Félix-Pyat,
et au départ, j'étais plutôt partie
sur une carrière
d'assistante sociale, ou d'avocate
ou de magistrate,
la preuve,
j'étais en 1re année de droit...
-Et il vous embarque
sur les clips, d'abord...
-Et moi, en réalité,
j'ai une carrière assez linéaire
dans la production.
J'ai démarré stagiaire,
et je finis productrice,
mais en 25 ans.
Tout le monde pense, maintenant
qu'on parle un peu plus de moi...
-Vous avez gravi les échelons
petit à petit.
Le premier, c'est Akhenaton.
-Intellectuellement,
je me retrouvais en lui.
Même en désaccord !
On n'est pas d'accord sur tout.
-Vous avez produit
des films, des séries,
des documentaires, et un jour,
Netflix vous contacte
pour sa 1re grosse série française,
"Marseille",
avec Gérard Depardieu,
Benoît Magimel.
Là, une fois de plus,
votre travail a consisté
à ouvrir des portes...
-C'est Dan Franck,
le créateur de la série,
mon témoin de mariage.
-Vous l'avez aidé à prendre
le pouls de la ville ?
-Absolument.
Sans ça,
il ne pouvait pas y tourner.
Pascal Breton,
le producteur,
l'a compris tout de suite.
-Ce travail que vous avez fait
sur Netflix, ça a servi de déclic
pour prendre conscience
que vous pouviez convaincre ?
C'est le déclic aussi,
quelque part,
de cette confiance en vous
pour vous lancer en politique ?
-Oui.
La confiance en soi, oui,
et surtout la conscience
de ce qu'il y avait à faire,
des engagements à prendre.
-Vous racontez
votre parcours personnel
dans un livre qui s'appelle
"Moi, la France, je la kiffe".
Enfance dans une famille nombreuse
d'un quartier pauvre de Marseille.
Vos parents sont nés en Algérie.
-Mon père. Ma mère,
à Salon-de-Provence.
-Vous avez grandi
dans une double culture.
Pour vous, il n'y a pas d'ambiguïté,
votre pays, c'est la France.
Vous "kiffez" la France.
Pourquoi ressentez-vous
ce besoin de l'affirmer comme ça ?
-Parce que, malheureusement,
et c'est très franco-français,
on vous ramène souvent
à vos origines ethniques
- c'est curieux -
et à vos origines sociales.
C'est souvent
"d'où tu viens ?",
"c'est quoi, ta religion ?".
Je me suis amusée
en parlant de couscous
et de bouillabaisse
en parlant des idées préconçues
qui consistent à dire que,
parce que tu es maghrébine,
tu vas plus aimer...
C'était une provoc'.
C'était une manière provocante
de dire les choses.
On nous ramène souvent,
et le président l'a dit souvent,
on nous ramène souvent
à nos origines,
et c'est terrible.
Bien sûr, ça englobe
notre personnalité,
ça nous construit,
mais moi, je suis française.
Il n'y a pas de sujet, pour moi.
-Vous aimez la France,
une France ouverte, tolérante,
plurielle.
Le 21 avril 2002,
quand Jean-Marie Le Pen
se qualifie pour le second tour,
ça vous met dans une colère noire,
vous décidez de quitter la France
et vous allez vivre au Maroc
pendant plusieurs années.
Vous prendriez
la même décision aujourd'hui,
en étant députée ?
Vous quitteriez le navire
en pleine tempête ?
-C'est surtout
parce que j'ai vieilli.
-Vous réagiriez différemment.
-On ne réagit pas pareil à 25 ans
qu'à 46 ans, c'est une évidence.
Je ne reprendrais pas
la même décision.
Ca, je me suis questionnée.
On ne quitte pas le navire,
c'est ce que je me suis dit
quand je suis revenue.
Je me suis rendu compte qu'on vivait
dans le plus beau pays du monde
quand je suis allée ailleurs.
Je réalise aussi
qu'on rend mal à la France
ce qu'elle donne,
et quelle que soit l'origine.
-On passe à notre quiz.
Je vous explique :
je commence une phrase,
et c'est à vous de la compléter.
C'est bon, on y va ?
-On y va.
-"Dans l'hémicycle,
le meilleur comédien..."
-Le meilleur comédien ?
-Vous, la productrice...
-C'est moi.
-C'est vous ? Non ?
-On peut dire ce qu'on veut.
Non, je sais pas...
Le meilleur comédien...
Il y en a trop.
J'ai du mal à choisir, mais je...
Non, après,
ça mettrait des collègues
dans l'embarras.
Je dirais que c'est moi.
C'est moi, parce qu'en réalité,
je suis la productrice...
-Vous jouez un rôle
quand vous êtes dans l'Assemblée ?
-Non, mais si vous me permettez
juste une citation
de Nassim Nicholas Taleb :
"Il vaut mieux avoir la conscience
de l'ignorance
"que la certitude du savoir."
-Bon. "Plus je fais de la politique,
plus je me dis que..."
-"C'est compliqué."
-Au point de vous dire que...
Un seul mandat ?
-Je peux comprendre,
en réalité, la désaffection
des gens pour la politique.
-Donc, un seul mandat,
a priori ?
-J'ai commencé avec Emmanuel Macron,
j'en aurai fini avec lui.
-"J'ai beau être
"marseillaise,
mais à Paris..."
-"C'est une très belle ville."
-Quand même, vous le dites !
-Une magnifique ville.
-On va terminer
l'émission en musique.
Vous reconnaissez cette chanson ?
-La vie est belle
Le destin s'en écarte
-IAM, "Nés sous la même étoile".
-C'est l'une des chansons
les plus connues du groupe IAM.
-Là, on allait tourner
au Frioul.
On a tourné de partout.
-Votre histoire aurait pu
ressembler à celle de ce gamin
évoqué dans cette chanson ?
-Evidemment, sans les parents
que j'ai eus.
-Vous devez votre parcours...
-Je dois tout à ma mère,
ma grand-mère...
-Et à l'importance accordée
à l'éducation ?
-Oui,
et à la conscience
de ce qu'on était
dans le monde, non pas que recevoir,
mais donner.
On oublie beaucoup...
Voilà.
-C'est le mot de la fin.
Merci,
Sabrina Agresti-Roubache,
d'être venue dans cette émission.
-Merci beaucoup.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
"Nés sous la même étoile", IAM
...